just a sandwich
who are you was in yours controlling the
person front just sound her right now
just stay with him Chris don't leave me
please get back here
we're holding a fine can forget we're
fine shortly
come on max dead god damn it they really
might be did to know I never understood
that what should I say we do people do I
said can you go out of it I was damaged
just go your stuff you everything this
is anything new
neckbreaker proceed
oh I saw balance it away it is a nice
thing I really it's like one of the only
machines I'm not doing that now you did
one with Mike no but you did oh you did
really well yeah I could chase your turn
all right yes you come back I kill Matt
and we both [ __ ] up on Josh so this
way I don't want to say yeah just set
those
corsets walked anyway those
oh you come through yeah okay I think
there's some [ __ ] it is just go Chris
why the hell is Drew Cisco Chris Chris
Chris so they had that was something
that I couldn't go this way I wanted
Chris yeah Chris Chris Chris Chris Chris
hey but don't do it leave it boys you
just you just compute Fantas think you
know someone dude Chris why'd she going
through myself I know common was just
following something you know some only
hands really there's no these are gonna
to they listen together
I'm not gonna lie if I could make the
checks out what else probably Sam right
now that was my you know she's a towel
yeah see that's why when I had that
choice that came up I should actually
it's not like you know like she wasn't
annoying star when she was getting like
that she's so this this day because I
wanted this is gonna be real jump scary
way to Crisco residents together please
stay together all the time
keep looking for Union was upset and
where was it
during the boiler room oh dear dear
again this is really critical places
okay I think this is the final minute
plates on this is basically cheating but
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna look at
that garden strike again and see what
Chris did to put the gun down
because as the guidance turning here he
put the gun down so I think he's gonna
kill himself when we have the choice we
choose to kill him if it gives us that
choice between shoot Christian Ashley I
think we choose him because then he'll
shoot me he'll put the gun down I think
that's what that looks like right yeah
and this is a guidance tone he looks
like he's gonna kill him he looks like
as I try and do it and he's like me not
I can't do it yeah no that's right you
know because she saw the wing that's why
I shot her but she got it but that's a
Godman sternum okay I understand your
brain with me yayan we're in a hunson
right absolutely yeah we should we can
cook we can I want to like do it without
you say that she's imagining those
wouldn't see me close like right now no
I do not think that's something jumps
out whether the conviction for game can
work I was playing it without looking at
it right now
while going to visit Lana what's up let
it go it's not yes I was just leaning
against the wall it said nothing to know
you know that door will open I think so
I think we just have a look at the stuff
first
you know this probably see this foot
loose here
just look around we don't return the
clothes that we're finding with those
photos they're probably really
significant there's a fight family
photos right there they are categorized
into different sections between so this
is all the stuff to do it man your bed
is all put in you and then 1952 don't
know what that's referring to this is
all 1952 I think is all the nos that was
the most the pelvis we learned that when
the girls fellows to clip the old mats
you know that's the master say they
found so 1952 this is all the center
whatever have we missed was a was the
attack we missed someone slip on in
there yeah mystery man I don't know what
this dream office is about to get one so
this is all the stuff Victor or is it
this is that is that's Victor see I was
thinking that victim was the one that
was it
whatever but they're separated so they
must be to 19 1952 one mystery mount the
same person - it's a victor who we
thought was because that said awesome on
it once you to do in connection with
both degree offset events as well as
various dips but he's also that one so
that's the same person also the cigars
but the cigar is at this resource to got
the other places to color and the axe I
don't know too much stuff too much who
gets the gun that's how next one it's in
say like at least about fly fix we've
had an ID or these were I think so yeah
so every time you play you may get
different that one is all stick together
like white once bitten so these are the
only ones that we have left and I think
that this is the next one in that it's
empty and that we want Chris to shoot up
to not shoes we wanted to end it himself
in silver right I have a really like
that
yes those are my kitchen there's no
handle
this is what she should swear she
captured this this looks like why I
saying right through and should push
that down that's why it's broken out
this is where Sam ran through huh
there's no handle did she take the hit I
don't have maybe get back to think it
was just the same thing that we just
looked like yeah
maybe Swiss to get somebody other thing
really hot there it's really obvious
about that kind of stuff yeah but where
is it
yeah Chris can you just stick with me
what risky just me with them come with
me how's the ointment
I think you scared that's it place to
skin it's just letting her man up drops
out I'm certain nothing
do ya oh she's pointing you did see that
yes yeah I trust her crazy
okay well Chris is going there as well
so let's follow him anyway
we're [ __ ] your spine Chris this way
okay
yet how to use tell my wrists all right
up or down it's going around
our Tea Party and its home in the other
way
like Betsy for your game playing is when
I play this Ford immediately she's angry
it was [ __ ] screwed oh that's
something else pops as well
Hannah's diary finally agreed the
invitations are out body's gonna happen
I hate that have to wait so far extra
not nothing for months so this is better
in school okay yeah this wasn't this
time I just left school yeah that's
right theater school they told me that
was awful
whose idea was it I think it was well we
know that Sam was protested Emily's you
mean answering it no I don't think that
Ash would do that
no maybe Emily yeah Emily would I feel
like they were both in on it
cuz I mean if they do I see it yeah he
do
but our choices could be like different
enough that what I think he's gonna
happen he doesn't even happen
she sort of notice one yeah
original web projectors that doesn't
really mean anything to me except for
the dog hassle we had a project up ahead
tell se you take the seasons into
context is what we do
wait which way am I facing right now
this way yes yeah maybe that was the
telephone I just don't I don't know what
a lot of things are anything has they
know she's Japanese
so really good is walking around crazy
so same way somebody does but the real
world doesn't look like that you prove I
did the type it doesn't look like that
though we don't have allergies
I don't going to take any more of this
forget last year ever happened in Gaza
yeah
so yeah the town was the one that but I
think we made only stupid yes
if it was you
I'm speaking from
definitely all wrong which I think so
she didn't - she wasn't involved in life
the setup was that because she told us
what she thinks it's really bad or she's
just changed her mind
yeah baby I heard that too yeah it would
be really hard Alina friend
courageous so reluctant
no choice and their courageous yeah
I think Sam's fines but that's what I
would have said I was actually can you
imagine leaving someone behind like we
just looked at a dog you'd even remember
that from oh and Sam to it real like Sam
soon as I was still very proud of my
efforts in saving Sam which I think I
did sounds really nice I hope you find
her
I feel like we're not going to just
because no way this once but this
doesn't look like the kind of marriage
you need yeah what are you questioning
going on down here
yeah
Tolson what is that conversation me
there's something that we make it all
connect
will tell us me that's to tell me it's
reminding me what to stick at really say
just do it another Christian you follow
me please dude Chris thank you come on
the race
what oh she looks your face straight
Oh Chris Chris buddy
he's gonna follow me now I guess Chuck
oh my god Eric don't know me this
dangerous waiting
this is weird this is like a part of the
house to Chris hello Chris sees
flashlight so that's good you know so
much action I think it's what I'd like
to kill its way here I think yes that it
is well let's go we go back to text
that's it that's all special patrolman
no it's me it's a six
Mike Sam Josh Ashley Emily has two x's
on our eyes that's weird
and it's worse wasn't the iho Steven and
here's not on that mat so what that one
is
that's none of them is just Mike Matt
Josh that dress on
I met Sam Emily Chris and Ashley Matt
and Jess armor letter J both said it
always a lot that means that was the one
sunrise isn't she could be blind or
she's captured something something to it
but the resident my life Sam's a watch
that's good that's good that's good yep
this is very good we have Sam
Krister scar grass buddy
Briggs what [ __ ] to go
yeah Sam since my next one
we'll never gonna get separated back up
that's the bad guy
no that's the bad-news our long time I
want to go with him did you go yeah but
what if I get most Annette hood Chris
you know I'm sticking with him whatever
but then I get stuck in the other
and that was it
carefully the hey looks meat pigs well
then what's that dead pig
yeah sorry do we have two bad guys on my
ex blood that's big pot of course it is
it's true
lower them to places with the pigs
blaming each other encourage us with
cool and a fear of God Sam I thought she
was fine
I thought she was a gig today heathen
yeah but it's it fainted which way to go
straight yeah I do thinking it was
turned over to methanol Christy [ __ ]
hurry up yeah who said and pull this
witness of not where to go I don't think
so and I think that day we get banished
like that's that's giving us too much
that's too nice I think he just follows
really far behind so that Toby said that
it doesn't annoy us in a Camry
that's it
I think it's just the mosque so I think
he's pretty this is what we would see
when I do this that dummy would stand it
we Sam's okay right now this is the gun
where we're making the decision to ship
Chris or do nothing maybe now it looked
like he was gonna shoot something it I
mean cheetah
we're not sure yet I really don't miss
up he's holding it why you like to see
her she when she said show yourself they
pretend is encouraged yep yep we
together on this decision yes we've
already killed three [ __ ] people
we sex him
now we must make another at some time
you can take that in front of you Ashley
Ashley
it'll be nice
nothing
in the guidance so I said go [ __ ]
yourself yeah
[ __ ] we're not taking her son up in our
face talking the very birth time
no overtime
it looks like who's going to shoot
himself right yeah and then he stopped
Mindy so him but I didn't know Chris on
my trip real honest
Krystal nothing it's a guidance yes its
image is to put the gun down
we can't accomplish the gun down I can't
put the gun down
it's either Ashwin's either I shoot him
or I do nothing which one it looks like
he was gonna shoot himself
I reckon why was it don't put down I
don't I don't know I can't put it down I
don't have the choice it's here or
nothing
what are we gonna do which one so you
wanna go him well what do you think I
have no [ __ ] clue
oh it's just another trick in front I'm
not gonna make this to us I hope I make
the [ __ ] choice I feel like how many
boys that we've got left to kill the
girls are a bit late I'm not shooting
Emily because that's not what he did in
that guidance okay then you've made the
decision no I do that just do nothing or
Chris I made one decision you have to
make the other one what do you mean for
do nothing not shooting everything I
just went from talking around
potentially kill like a moon or should
it crease well I think that he was
putting the gun down here saying I'm not
doing English acts or nothing we're
doing up there yes
oh [ __ ] when I finish I do trophy
I just [ __ ] kill both of them you
just don't like sister a wife that was
previous
if they were both gonna die we should
have won it
using psychopath